these lead us to the question also with
listening this two question with a
question whether modernization goes
together with with fundamentalist
religion
well the of course is a question that we
could argue in the 80s in America nobody
will have such said such a thing in the
60s when the civil rights movement was
led by religion then religion was a very
positive thing and there it was in let's
say in the jacksonian democracy you have
the the evangelical Great Awakening is
goes hand-in-hand with it's actually an
democracy the movement and you could say
that actually have the democratization
of American religion which is not
anymore the New England clergy that
leads but it's very much led by the
people the ministry changes radically
into basically ordinary lady becoming
the ministers and so you have a kind of
democratization of religion that goes
hand-in-hand with with the political
democratization what happened is that
the religion is involved at every
contestation and both sides of the
barricades in abolitionism you have
religion the same Baptist religion which
in the north becomes one of the most
radical abolitionists is the Baptist
religion in the South that becomes the
defender of slavery and the same you
would say about the role of religion in
the in the in the woman suffrage and you
have the same thing so basically in any
fundamental political transformation the
kind of the key events from Civil War
abolition to the 23rd is the emergence
of a kind of public education of the
prayers etc the sixties the civil rights
movement religion has been very very
important so the notion that somehow
modernization produced only fundamental
is religion this is something we have
because of the specific context of the
1960s you could say Weber fundamentalism
actually goes back to the to the 1910s
when first emerges this category in
that's true and here again you could say
that this cannot be separated I mean
this is something which I have three
kind of process of secretary scissors
and religion has gone through American
society the first emergence of
fundamentalism was against a very
particular form of simply bringing
liberal theology because of the very
unique fusion of theology in America I
mean I don't want to go into date into
that it had also to do with with
basically except in Catholicism a
certain region also to do I mean the
last Protestant crusade in which all the
Protestants conservatives and liberals
could get together was in the in the
prohibition movement and it was a
movement directed against Catholics
basically as immigrants that later
accepted the Puritan model of of the
Sabbath
but so it's a complicated story there
fundamentalism itself is is not we have
not to be fundamentalism as a
traditional is defense of tradition it's
a very radical modern phenomenon it cost
whether with Jack urbanism they're
basically fundamentalist are radical
people with religion are very radical
very modern but in a very particular way
and in all traditions I would say they
may have been very strong a communist
strain certainly in Islam